Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de "Parlement hebdo".
Heureux de vous retrouver.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pour la dernière émission
de cette année 2023,
on accueille Ian Brossat.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes sénateur
communiste de Paris,
porte-parole du Parti
Communiste Français
et coprésident
du groupe communiste
au Conseil de Paris.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est le texte
le plus attendu
de cette fin d'année.
L'Assemblée nationale entame
ce lundi l'examen
du projet de loi immigration.
Les députés
ont sensiblement réécrit
la version qui avait été
votée, et durcie
par les sénateurs.
A la veille de ce débat,
la droite
fait monter la pression
sur le gouvernement.
La majorité
sénatoriale a déposé
une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
pour demander un référendum
sur l'immigration.
On parlera aussi
du projet de loi
de finances 2024
qui est en discussion
au Sénat.
Les sénateurs
ont notamment rejeté
le budget du logement.
Ils estiment
que le gouvernement
ne répond pas assez
à la crise actuelle
du logement.
- Alexandre Poussart:
L'examen du projet
de loi immigration
commence ce lundi
à l'Assemblée nationale
en séance publique.
Deux semaines de débats
qui s'annoncent tendues.
Le texte a déjà été remanié
par la commission
de loi de l'Assemblée.
- En commission,
les députés ont largement validé
la nouvelle version
du projet de loi.
- Sur l'ensemble de la loi
pour contrôler l'immigration
et améliorer l'intégration,
qui vote pour?
Il y a donc 16 voix contre.
La loi est votée.
- Les députés ont rétabli
l'aide médicale d'Etat
que les sénateurs
de droite
avaient limitée à une aide
médicale d'urgence.
La commission des lois
a également supprimé
le délit de séjour irrégulier.
Concernant
le titre de séjour
dans les métiers
en tension, un amendement
de compromis a été adopté.
Le préfet pourra
s'opposer à sa délivrance
en cas de menace
à l'ordre public,
de non-respect
des valeurs
de la République
ou encore de polygamie.
- Je pense que nous atteignons
une disposition conforme
à la cible qui était la nôtre.
Le dispositif a été resserré.
Il permet de tirer
de l'illégalité
et parfois de conditions
inacceptables
de maltraitance
un certain nombre
de ressortissants
en situation irrégulière.
- L'amendement
des sénateurs communistes
pour donner un titre
de séjour aux étrangers
qui dénonceraient
un marchand de sommeil
a été conservé
et étendu aux victimes
de proxénètes.
L'interdiction
de placement en centre
de rétention
administrative concernera
les mineurs
de moins de 18 ans
et non plus 16 ans,
comme dans la version sénatoriale.
Coup d'envoi des débats
dans l'hémicycle,
lundi à 16h.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va parler du fond
du texte, mais avant cela,
les députés écologistes
vont déposer lundi une motion
de rejet préalable
du projet de loi immigration.
Ca veut dire
que si cette motion
est adoptée,
le texte est rejeté
en séance
publique, il n'y
a plus de débat.
Est-ce que vous souhaitez
que cette motion
de rejet aboutisse?
Vous souhaitez
que le débat ait lieu
sur l'immigration?
- Ian Brossat:
je souhaite
que cette motion
soit adoptée
et qu'on puisse enfin parler
des vrais problèmes
des Français.
Je suis frappé
par le fait
que l'on parle
aujourd'hui, matin,
midi et soir, d'immigration.
On ne parle jamais des enjeux
du pouvoir d'achat,
jamais du niveau
des prix et jamais
des salaires.
Si on écoute
la macronie, la droite
et l'extrême droite,
on a un espace politique
qui est saturé par les questions
d'immigration.
Tout ce qui nous permettra
de revenir
aux vrais problèmes
des Français
et de ne pas passer
trois semaines
sur ce texte est bon à prendre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le texte
avait déjà été durci
par la majorité sénatoriale.
Vous êtes satisfait
par le rééquilibrage
sur la mesure
des métiers en tension?
- Ian Brossat:
Le texte tel qu'il sortait
du Sénat ressemblait à un tract
du Front National
des années 80.
Les députés ont fait
leur travail
en commission
des lois,
et ils ont un peu
rééquilibré ce texte,
même si l'équilibre
global reste
très mauvais à mes yeux.
Pour ce qui concerne
la régularisation
des travailleurs
sans papiers, nous,
les communistes,
nous y sommes favorables.
Quand quelqu'un
travaille en France,
quand quelqu'un
paie des impôts
et des cotisations
sociales, oui,
il doit
avoir la possibilité
d'avoir des papiers.
On ne peut pas avoir des secteurs
entiers
de notre économie
qui reposent
sur des gens
qui n'ont pas de papiers.
C'est notamment le cas
dans l'hôtellerie
et la restauration.
Nous sommes favorables
à la régularisation
de tous les travailleurs
sans papiers.
Le fait de travailler,
parfois
depuis des années en France,
doit donner lieu
à des papiers
pour que ces personnes aient
les mêmes droits
que n'importe
quel travailleur.
-
Kathia Gilder:
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à ceux qui disent
qu'il y a un risque
de créer un appel d'air
pour de nouveaux
travailleurs sans papiers
qui viendraient?
- Ian Brossat:
Les personnes qui disent
cela n'ont rien compris.
On parle de travailleurs
qui sont déjà là.
J'ai rencontré
encore l'autre jour,
à une mobilisation
de travailleurs Uber Eats,
des sans-papiers
qui travaillent
pour 30 euros par jour.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est de l'exploitation?
- Ian Brossat: Oui.
Cette exploitation
est liée
au fait
qu'ils n'aient pas de papiers.
C'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de papiers
qu'on peut les traiter comme ça.
Il faut leur permettre
d'accéder
aux mêmes droits
que n'importe
quel travailleur.
C'est bon pour eux,
mais aussi
pour le monde du travail
dans son ensemble.
Ca nous permet
de sortir d'une logique
qui tire tout le monde
vers le bas.
Je pense que c'est nécessaire.
Les députés communistes
vont travailler
pour étendre cet
article de telle sorte
qu'il puisse concerner tous
les travailleurs sans-papiers,
y compris
les travailleurs
qui ont un statut
d'autoentrepreneur.
- Alexandre Poussart:
En commission,
les députés ont rétabli
l'aide médicale d'Etat
qui avait été restreinte
par la majorité
de droite du Sénat.
Cette semaine,
un rapport commandé
par le gouvernement
a été rendu public.
Il reconnait
que cette aide est utile
et nécessaire,
mais il prévoit certains coups
de rabot.
Est-ce que pour vous,
il faut réformer
cette aide?
- Ian Brossat:
Il faut la préserver.
Je suis ravi
de voir qu'on remet
un peu de raison dans ce débat.
On parle de gens
qui ont besoin
d'être soignés.
C'est un principe
de base,
quand des gens
sont malades:
on leur permet
d'accéder aux soins.
L'idée même
de remettre en cause
ce principe fondamental est,
pour moi, profondément scandaleux.
Je note que ce rapport,
qui a été rédigé aussi
par Patrick
Stefanini
qui n'est pas un dangereux
gauchiste, puisqu'il
était directeur de campagne
de Valérie Pécresse,
a fait un certain
nombre de suggestions.
C'est une claque
monumentale
pour ceux qui,
à droite, du côté
des LR, ont voulu
supprimer cette aide.
C'est un des leurs
qui leur dit
que ce serait une absurdité.
- Kathia Gilder:
Les députés en commission
des lois ont conservé
certaines propositions,
notamment la facilitation
de l'expulsion
des délinquants
ou des criminels délinquants.
- Ian Brossat:
Quand on est en présence
de quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de papiers,
qui est clandestin,
qui est dangereux,
dont les services
de renseignement
nous disent
qu'il est dangereux,
je ne suis pas choqué
qu'on l'éloigne
du territoire français.
- Alexandre Poussart:
C'est une ligne
de fracture au sein de la gauche?
La France Insoumise
dit
qu'elle est contre cette "double
peine".
- Ian Brossat:
Ce n'est pas une double peine.
Ce sont des personnes
qui sont en situation
de clandestinité et sans-papiers.
En plus de cela,
quand on a tous
les éléments
qui nous indiquent
que ces personnes
sont dangereuses,
je ne suis pas
pour que ces personnes restent
sur le territoire français.
Je pense que tout le monde
est d'accord là-dessus.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous êtes donc d'accord
avec ces propositions.
- Ian Brossat:
Aujourd'hui, une personne
qui est en situation
irrégulière,
on a la possibilité
de l'expulser,
a fortiori
quand elle est considérée
comme dangereuse.
Il n'y a pas de raison
de changer
de la loi pour le faire.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y a aussi
des étrangers réguliers
qui ont été condamnés
pour des délits.
- Ian Brossat:
Pour ce qui concerne
une personne
en situation régulière,
je suis pour qu'elle
soit sanctionnée
comme n'importe
quelle personne
qui est sur le territoire
français.
Ce serait donc de la prison.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'amendement des sénateurs
communistes donne
un titre de séjour
aux étrangers
qui dénonceraient un marchand
de sommeil.
La disposition
a même été étendue
aux victimes de proxénètes.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que cette mesure sera conservée
et qu'il faut la conserver
dans le projet
de loi?
- Ian Brossat: Je le souhaite.
C'est la seule avancée
qui ait été obtenue
par la gauche au Sénat.
Je suis très heureux
qu'avec mon groupe,
nous l'ayons portée.
L'idée,
c'est que vous avez aujourd'hui
des personnes
qui sont victimes de marchands
de sommeil.
Je l'ai vu dans le cadre
de mon mandat d'adjoint
au maire à Paris.
40% des victimes
de marchands de sommeil
n'ont pas de papiers.
Ces personnes
sont donc victimes
de cette exploitation.
Elles n'osent pas porter
plainte précisément
parce qu'elles n'ont pas
de papiers.
Elles ont peur,
en allant au commissariat,
de subir une OQTF.
Nous disons qu'il faut
les protéger,
leur permettre
d'accéder à un titre
de séjour provisoire,
ce qui permettra
de les reloger.
Le problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'on exproprie
des immeubles
qui sont la propriété
des marchands
de sommeil
parce que si vous n'avez
pas de papiers,
vous ne pouvez pas déposer
une demande de logement.
Ca permettra de mieux
repérer les situations
de marchands de sommeil,
de les condamner
et de permettre
à ces personnes
de les reloger
et d'avoir une vie digne
après avoir subi
des choses atroces.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On continue
à parler d'immigration.
Les Républicains
veulent modifier
la Constitution
pour mieux maîtriser
notre politique
migratoire et soumettre
le sujet à un référendum français.
Une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
a été défendue
hier sans succès
par les députés
Les Républicains
et elle sera débattue
la semaine prochaine
au Sénat.
Les sénateurs
centristes
ne sont pas d'accord
avec leurs collègues
de la majorité au Sénat,
les sénateurs
Les Républicains.
- Coup dur pour les LR au Sénat.
Mercredi, en commission,
leurs alliés centristes
ont rejeté
deux articles phares
de leur proposition de loi.
Ce texte est emblématique
pour la droite sénatoriale.
- Il faut permettre
aux Français
de se déterminer
pour deux raisons.
La première,
c'est qu'il n'y
a pas un phénomène qui ait
autant bouleversé
la société française
depuis un demi-siècle
sans que les Français n'aient
jamais été consultés
et surtout, le résultat
d'un référendum s'impose.
- La proposition de loi
constitutionnelle prévoyait
d'élargir à la question
migratoire
les conditions
du recours au référendum
en modifiant l'article 11
de la Constitution.
Pour les centristes,
c'était une ligne rouge.
- Vouloir faire ça,
c'est dangereux,
mais ce sera
encore plus dangereux demain.
Si madame Le Pen
arrive au pouvoir
et qu'on lui donne
les moyens de faire
un référendum,
on pourrait
avoir de grandes difficultés.
- Autre proposition
qui s'est heurtée
à l'opposition
des centristes:
que des lois organiques
puissent déroger
aux accords internationaux
ou aux droits européens
si les règles européennes
contreviennent
à l'identité
constitutionnelle
de la France.
- Le droit de l'Union
Européenne
est un droit qui s'impose
au droit international
et au droit
des parlementaires,
dans ce domaine,
mais aussi dans d'autres domaines.
Nous ne voulons pas inverser
la hiérarchie
des normes.
- Du côté
de l'exécutif, s'il
n'était pas hostile
à l'idée d'élargir
le référendum à des sujets
sociétaux, Emmanuel Macron
y a finalement renoncé,
faute de consensus.
Selon le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
la proposition de loi
du groupe LR s'apparente
à un double Frexit européen
et constitutionnel.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Avant de parler
du fond de cette réforme,
on va parler
de l'enjeu politique.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que les sénateurs
Les Républicains,
qui sont quand même
le premier
groupe au Sénat,
vont être en minorité
sur ce texte?
- Ian Brossat:
Ca commence déjà à ressembler
à un fiasco.
En commission
des lois au Sénat,
ils ont été
battus également
sur les deux principaux
articles
de leur proposition de loi
constitutionnelle,
à la fois sur la question
du référendum,
et sur la question
de la dérogation
au droit européen.
Or, c'était
quand même là-dessus
que cette proposition
reposait
pour l'essentiel,
notamment
parce que les centristes
et la gauche
ont rejeté ces deux dispositions.
Pour l'instant,
c'est un fiasco,
et tant mieux.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Il va y avoir une nouvelle
alliance
pour combattre ce texte?
- Ian Brossat:
Vous allez peut-être vite
en besogne.
Il y a encore au Sénat
des gens
qui gardent quelques réflexes.
En l'occurrence,
quand des propositions
ahurissantes
leur sont soumises,
ils ont des réflexes
républicains
qui sont quand même
un peu nécessaires
si on a envie que nos institutions
fonctionnent.
- Kathia Gilder:
Sur le fond,
est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée de réviser
la Constitution
pour mieux maîtriser
notre politique migratoire?
-
Ian Brossat:
C'est ce que je vous disais.
Ces gens saturent
l'espace politique
avec les questions
d'immigration
tout le temps.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est une stratégie?
- Ian Brossat: Bien sûr.
On vient de finir
d'analyser le projet
de loi immigration
au Sénat,
et on a maintenant
un débat sur la réforme
de la Constitution
uniquement
autour de l'enjeu migratoire.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca se termine en fiasco.
- Ian Brossat:
A force de jouer
avec le feu, on finit
par se cramer.
C'est ce qui est
en train de se produire.
Je n'en suis pas insatisfait.
Ca peut leur servir de leçon.
J'espère qu'un
jour, quand même,
au Parlement,
on pourra débattre
des vrais problèmes
des gens: les salaires,
le travail,
tout ce qui fait
que les gens
n'auront
peut-être pas les moyens
d'acheter
des cadeaux de Noël.
Ils disent qu'il faut déroger
aux règles européennes.
Les mêmes ont voté tous
les traités européens.
Ils sont passés
par le traité de Lisbonne
pour passer par-dessus
le vote des Français
en 2005 et ils nous disent
maintenant
qu'on va déroger aux traités
européens uniquement
sur la question de l'immigration.
En réalité,
sur la question des Droits
de l'homme.
Ce sont quand même
des traités qui concernent
les Droits de l'homme.
La France va ressembler
à la Pologne
et à la Hongrie.
Mon modèle
pour la France,
qui est quand même
un grand pays,
ce n'est ni la Pologne
ni la Hongrie.
La France, le pays
des Droits de l'homme,
se doit
d'avoir encore quelques grands
principes qu'on respecte.
J'espère que ce fiasco
va servir
de leçon.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pourquoi
ne pas demander
l'avis des Français
sur ce sujet migratoire?
- Ian Brossat:
Qu'est-ce qu'on va demander
aux Français
sur la question migratoire?
- Alexandre Poussart:
Sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papiers.
Ca peut être une question.
- Ian Brossat:
On a eu des millions
de Français qui ont manifesté
pour obtenir
un référendum
sur les retraites,
on leur a dénié le droit
de se prononcer
sur une réforme
comme celle-là et maintenant,
on va réformer
la Constitution
pour leur poser une question
sur l'immigration?
On commence par poser
aux Français
les questions qu'ils attendent.
Ils attendaient
d'être interrogés
sur la question des retraites.
Si certains cherchent
d'autres idées,
on peut aussi
interroger les Français
par référendum,
c'est une proposition
que nous faisons
avec Fabien Roussel,
sur l'indexation des prix.
Quand les prix augmentent,
les salaires augmentent d'autant.
Que l'on fasse ça,
ça permettra de répondre davantage
aux préoccupations des Français.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce jeudi, à l'Assemblée nationale,
les députés LR
ont déposé un tas
de textes au titre de leur journée
d'initiative parlementaire.
Il y avait notamment
une proposition
de résolution qui appelle
le gouvernement
à dénoncer l'accord
franco-algérien
de 1968, accord
qui facilite l'arrivée
de ressortissants
algériens
et de leur famille
sur le territoire.
Ca a été rejeté
par l'Assemblée nationale
ce jeudi.
Vous vous en félicitez?
- Ian Brossat: Oui.
Je note que c'est quand même
le troisième texte
qui concerne les questions
d'immigration.
Je me félicite que ce texte
ait été refusé.
Quel est le sujet, en fait?
On considère
qu'il y a trop d'Algériens
en France?
Je ne partage pas cette vision
des choses.
Je vis dans le 18e arrondissement
de Paris, qui a notamment
été un lieu
où se sont installés
beaucoup d'Algériens.
C'est quoi, le sujet?
Pourquoi on a besoin
en permanence
de réveiller
de vieilles querelles?
Ces gens sont quand même obsédés.
Ils ont des obsessions
permanentes
sur un certain
nombre de sujets
que je ne partage pas.
- Kathia Gilder:
Pourtant, Elisabeth Borne envisage
une renégociation de ce traité.
- Ian Brossat:
Il ne vous aura pas échappé
que je ne suis pas le porte-parole
d'Elisabeth Borne.
Je ne veux pas qu'on touche
à ce sujet.
De manière
générale,
je ne partage pas l'idée
selon laquelle l'immigration
serait une espèce
de menace
dont il faudrait se prémunir.
Quand il y a des gens
dangereux,
il faut les écarter,
mais la grande majorité
des étrangers qui vit
sur le territoire français
travaille.
Ils veulent
vivre dignement
avec leur famille
et méritent
d'être respectés.
On n'a pas besoin
d'agiter ça en permanence
comme le font certains.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Eric Ciotti
a proposé d'instaurer
une rétention
de sûreté pour les personnes
condamnées
pour terrorisme
et qui sont sorties
de prison
et qui seraient jugées
encore dangereuses.
Cette rétention de sûreté pourrait
permettre d'éviter
de nouveaux attentats?
- Ian Brossat:
Quand quelqu'un a été condamné,
on peut l'assigner
à résidence,
par exemple.
Dans ce cas-là,
il faut des prisons
et des peines plus lourdes.
On n'a pas besoin
d'ajouter des éléments
dans notre droit,
comme le propose Eric Ciotti.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le droit actuel suffit?
- Ian Brossat: Oui,
à condition de l'appliquer.
On n'est pas au bout de l'enquête.
Il y a aussi la question
de la psychiatrie
qui est posée.
On est dans une situation
catastrophique
à ce niveau-là, dans notre pays.
Avant de proposer
des modifications législatives,
il faut regarder
de près les événements
qui se sont déroulés.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le Sénat continue d'examiner
le projet de loi
de finances pour 2024,
et notamment les moyens
financiers donnés
aux différents ministères.
Les sénateurs
ont rejeté le budget
du logement.
Vous avez été l'adjoint
d'Anne Hidalgo
à la mairie de Paris.
Vous connaissez
ces questions par coeur.
Ce budget du gouvernement
ne répond pas,
selon la majorité
sénatoriale,
à la crise actuelle du logement.
Ecoutez Dominique Estrosi Sassone.
- Les blocages
et les tensions
dont nous sommes
les témoins
dans le parcours
résidentiel
sont de puissants
vecteurs de frustration
et de ressentiment.
Ne pas pouvoir accéder
au logement social
ou ne pas pouvoir
en sortir, renoncer
à un emploi
ou à des études faute
de logement, ne pas réaliser
son rêve d'accéder
à la propriété,
voire d'acheter
une maison avec jardin
pour sa famille
comme ses parents,
ce sont autant
de faits qui alimentent
un sentiment
de déclassement,
de relégation ou d'assignation
à résidence.
A certains égards,
la révolte des gilets jaunes,
les émeutes
urbaines de cet été
ou encore
les réactions
de plus en plus agressives
contre Airbnb
sont autant d'éruptions
de violence face
aux injustices
dont le logement
est la cause ou le symptôme.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse?
Est-ce que la prochaine
crise,
c'est la crise
autour du logement
qui risque de mener
à une explosion sociale?
- Ian Brossat: Je pense que oui.
La situation du logement
est particulièrement tendue,
et catastrophique.
Le gouvernement porte
une lourde responsabilité.
Quand le gouvernement
a décidé de ponctionner
dans les caisses
des bailleurs HLM
en expliquant
que les bailleurs HLM
avaient des finances
extrêmement bonnes,
nous avions alerté.
Nous leur avions dit
qu'ils allaient ponctionner
des millions d'euros
dans les caisses
des bailleurs sociaux
et que cela allait
avoir des conséquences:
ils vont moins rénover
leur parc et la construction
de logements sociaux
va ralentir.
Le gouvernement
est totalement responsable
de la situation actuelle.
Vous avez aujourd'hui
une baisse
par rapport au début du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
de 15% de construction HLM.
On n'a jamais produit aussi peu
de logements sociaux
dans notre pays
alors qu'on n'a jamais eu
un besoin aussi important
de logements abordables.
Le gouvernement
en est largement responsable.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pourtant, le gouvernement porte
un budget du logement de 5
milliards d'euros
de plus par rapport
à l'an dernier.
- Ian Brossat:
C'est très largement insuffisant.
Les bailleurs sociaux
sont aujourd'hui
à sec,
parce que les collectivités
locales
ont de plus en plus de mal
aussi.
Quand vous faites
du logement social
ou du logement privé,
du logement familial,
vous avez besoin
d'équipements publics
comme des crèches ou des écoles.
On aurait besoin,
par exemple, de renouer
avec une vraie aide
de la part des bâtisseurs,
construire des logements
et des équipements publics
qui vont avec.
Il faut faciliter
le travail des maires.
Je pense que le gouvernement
est aujourd'hui
très loin
du compte
et ne se rend pas bien
compte des difficultés
de logement de nos concitoyens.
- Kathia Gilder:
Cette crise du logement
est une crise à multiples
facteurs complexes.
Le Sénat va lancer
une mission d'information
sur cette crise.
Quel doit
être l'objectif numéro 1
de cette mission?
- Ian Brossat: D'abord,
comment on relance
la construction?
Il faut construire
des logements sociaux
et des logements
abordables
dans notre pays.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il faut redonner envie
aux promoteurs.
- Ian Brossat: Oui,
et aux communes aussi.
Deuxièmement:
comment on régule mieux
le marché du logement?
Le constat
que je peux faire,
dans une ville
comme Paris,
c'est qu'on a de moins en
moins de possibilités
de construire
et on a en même temps
de plus en plus de logements
qui existent,
mais qui sont vides
les trois quarts
de l'année.
Comment on fait en sorte
que ces logement
soit remis sur le marché?
Cela pose la question
de la fiscalité
du logement.
Je souhaiterais
que l'on puisse taxer beaucoup
plus fermement
les résidences secondaires
et les logements vacants
dans les zones tendues,
pour que ces logements
soient remis
sur le marché.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il faudrait aussi encadrer
davantage les prix du marché
de l'immobilier?
- Ian Brossat:
Je souhaiterais par exemple
qu'on ait la possibilité
d'encadrer
les prix du foncier.
Le prix du foncier,
il est bien souvent exorbitant
et il a souvent
des conséquences
sur le prix du logement
que vous payez,
sur le prix de sortie.
La possibilité
d'encadrer les prix
du foncier, ce serait une avancée.
C'était proposé
dans le cadre du CNR
sur le logement
et le gouvernement
a malheureusement balayé
cette proposition
d'un revers de main.
- Kathia Gilder:
Des records de places
d'hébergement ont été créées.
- Ian Brossat:
Vous avez effectivement
aujourd'hui 203.000
places d'hébergement,
mais le constat
que nous faisons,
c'est qu'on a encore beaucoup
de gens
qui dorment
dehors
et qu'on en a de plus en plus,
notamment
des enfants.
L'Unicef l'a montré.
En un an, on a eu
+42% d'enfants
qui dorment dans la rue.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous avez défendu
un amendement sur le sujet.
- Ian Brossat:
Nous avons fait collectivement
adopter un amendement
au projet de loi
de finances au Sénat qui permet
de créer 6000 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires.
Ce que je souhaite,
c'est que le gouvernement conserve
ces 6000 places
supplémentaires
et qu'il ne balaye pas
cette proposition
d'un revers de main
par un nouveau 49.3.
Permettre à des enfants
d'avoir un toit
sur la tête
et de ne pas dormir
dans la rue, ça devrait
faire consensus.
Si on a été
capables de dégager
une majorité au Sénat
sur ce sujet,
le gouvernement pourrait
nous donner raison.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dernière question,
sur les locations de meublés
touristiques type Airbnb,
une proposition
de loi a été reportée
en raison d'une
obstruction des députés RN
et Les Républicains.
Vous connaissez
ce dossier par coeur
à Paris.
Pour vous, jusqu'où faut-il aller?
- Ian Brossat:
Les députés RN
se sont conduits
comme des larbins
de la multinationale américaine.
Je souhaite que dans certains
territoires,
on puisse interdire
ces locations touristiques
pour aider les classes moyennes.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce sera le mot de la fin.